Welcome to "English in a Minute",...
...where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
You probably have heard someone say,...
..."Break a leg."
Don't worry.
She isn't going to break someone's leg.
This is an expression that means good luck!
Let's listen to a conversation to find out.
I'm so nervous.
Tonight is the first night of the play.
Is it?
Well, go out there and break a leg!
This phrase began as a way to wish actors good luck.
Theater people said that if they wished each other something bad, good might happen.
So when you hear "break a leg," it really means "do well."
Also, it can mean to work really hard at something.
And that's English in a Minute.